thank you for joining us America Jose
where there's an Austin Texas side Joe
how are you doing well thank you for
taking my call sure what's up so uh
we're looking for a financial advisor
and a lot of information online says to
look for CFP I wanted to get your take
on it and more generally what you'll be
looking for in a financial advisor the
CFP is the certified financial planner
designation it is a rigorous field
process of study and usually takes a few
years to achieve minimum to you know
it's much akin to getting your CPA I
accept you have to get your CPA to
practice but I mean it's a it's a very
difficult process so CFPs are are all if
you find one that is a CFP they all have
good strong academic knowledge that's
the upside the downside is is they're
somewhat indoctrinated and some of them
can't see their way past you know in the
owned into doing their own critical
thinking in what they were taught and so
that's my only problem I run into with
them as they get and they have some
people have a tendency in the financial
world CFP is included to get just
paralysis of the analysis they get to
where they spend all their time majoring
in minors instead of dealing with the
main issues on the table so that's what
you want to be aware of but to see if in
other words I would not agree with your
online people that someone has to be a
CFP in order to give good financial
advice I disagree but it certainly is a
wonderful designation and it is a
rigorous field of study to give you an
ups to give you an understanding of it
I've got a lot of friends that are COF
peace a lot of them and a lot of our
people we endorse our CFP
so you just don't want you want them to
be a certified financial planner or not
a certified financial Pharisee you know
and that is some problem fall in the
ladder so then now what am I looking for
here's the rule I use first and foremost
in all financial advice
and that would include my lawyer that
does our estate planning my tax guy my
investment guy my real-estate person if
you were getting a mortgage insurance
those are all financial categories in
every case I'm looking for someone that
first and foremost has the heart of a
teacher every one of those fields that I
just mentioned teach people to sell
first and about 85 percent of the people
in every one of those fields I just
mentioned are salespeople you do not
want them I don't mind buying from them
but I don't want to have an interaction
with somebody where I constantly have my
shields up because I think they're
trying to sell me all the time because
they're trying to sell me all the time
you know and so what I want is I don't
my I don't you know I'm not worried
about a conflict of interest I don't
mind somebody making a commission on a
real estate transaction but the heart of
a teacher is this they want the customer
to understand the facts the situation
the market the history how the product
works everything about it so that then
the customer can make a wise buying
decision because the person that is that
mature knows that if you make an unwise
buying decision in the case we're
talking about here an investment that is
a bad investment and you didn't
understand what you were getting into
then then they're going to get blamed
and you're not going to continue to do
business with them so it is a long
horizon mindset it's a long time frame
mindset to bother to teach your
customers and so if I have a lawyer that
drops his glasses down the end of his
nose and starts talking down to me
I fire his butt because he got confused
about who he works for I'm not going to
be talked down to by any of these idiots
it is their job to teach me right and
then I'm going to make my decision so
when I'm in a legal situation and I'm
talking to our our in-house counsel and
maybe even we brought in someone from
the outside to advise us or we say okay
here's what we're facing this this this
and this this and this I say what would
you do and they tell me I say why would
you do that I'm learning in order to
make my own decision do you see the
difference
I'll go that's what you're looking for
is the heart of a teacher and when we
are doing our due diligence on the
financial advisors that we endorse that
is our primary filter that they don't
have slick on them you know that they
just they're good folk there they don't
have to make the sale today to hit some
quota or they're not pushing some
company crap you know they're just
they're just there to help and they know
if they help you that you're going to
send them your brother and your friend
and both your golfing buddies and they
know that if they do the right thing for
you and you learn and you're comfortable
then you're going to tell them about
your guy you know and that's how they
get their business instead of slicking
around on everybody and you can tell
when you meet with them and if you're
married your wife can really tell well
the wives can smell slick a mile away
you know and so that's the main thing
and then when you get in there if they
can't teach you that means they don't
know what the flip they're doing right
right and so now you know if the CFP did
them any good or not some people are
good at passing tests but that's all
they're good at but most the time I
would say if you got to see a PE of a
very at least academically knowledgeable
person now they may have fallen off in
the sales side of things and they may be
they may have slick on but I'm more
concerned about that part of the
discussion than I am the other so if you
know if you do want to connect up with
our people we call them smart Wester
pros we call you the smart Wester
because a smart investor learns to do it
themselves with help and guidance in the
multitude of counsel there is safety the
Bible says and so click on smart Wester
at Dave Ramsey comm and you can find the
people we recommend in your area the
smart investor pros in your area it'll
you can type in your information and
drop down a list of people in your area
and then you can choose among them or
not
doesn't matter but that's how that's one
of the primary ways we vet them and they
pay us an endorsement fee but we don't I
mean we don't do anything for that we do
it because we've so many people like you
in the last 25 years on the air that
have said hey Dave who cannot trust who
can I trust who can I trust and you know
and we follow up on every single person
and make sure that they were taking care
of
and every complaint if we run it to
ground and make sure that you know we
want to know exactly what happened any
kind of problem and if we have any
goofballs in there we would boo them out
pretty quick there's no guarantee but we
work hard at it you know making sure
they're the right kind of people hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]